So, auf den letzten Drücker, auf den letzten Drücker, ich habe noch nicht mal alles eingeschaltet, ich muss gerade mal nebenbei alles anmachen, moin, zack, rasch, so, mal gucken, was die heute zeigen, wahrscheinlich Tomb Raider und was auch immer, keine Ahnung, ich habe keinen Schimmer, was die in der Pipeline haben, Kingdom Hearts, haben sie wahrscheinlich noch,
äh, mal gucken, ob es irgendwas Final Fantasy mäßiges gibt, was, was macht eigentlich das Final Fantasy 7 Remake, wo sie auf die chlorreiche Idee gekommen sind, das muss man jetzt in Seasons machen, ne, das war das letzte, was ich davon gelesen habe, ja, da hoffe ich auch drauf, dass wir uns was von zeigen, okay, man, man weiß, man weiß nichts genaues, okay, ja, gut, da, da machst du nix, ne, da machst du nix.
Da machst du nix, komm mal, was soll das, Release Date Final Fantasy 7 Remake, ob es da schon irgendwas gab in der letzten Zeit mal, Release angeblichen, warum eigentlich, das muss, ich meine, nur weil das Spiel mehrere, wie viel, wie, hatte, wie viele CDs hatte das, 2 oder 4, weiß das jemand, wie viele CDs hatte Final Fantasy 7, aber ich meine, nur weil das auf mehreren CDs kommt, muss man natürlich mehrere Episoden daraus machen, weil, ich meine, das Game kam ja auch zusammen,
da waren halt mehrere CDs drin, was soll, was soll diese Episoden, so, so drittes, die sind da teilweise haben, muss man ja verstehen, so, posten wir mal auf, Twitters, äh, ich habe Englisch, das ist das Naturlayout, mal umstellen, Woodface, so, ich bin bereit, kann losgehen, achso, ne, ich bin nicht bereit, ich muss ja noch Final Fantasy starten,
ich sehe nix, VLC, zack, das ist ein voll immersives Stream-Erlebnis heute, was da, ja, ich glaube, das muss man wegmachen, machen wir mal VLC an und gucken uns das mal wieder in ordentlicher Auflösung an, in ordentlicher Qualität, natürlich mit maximalen FPS und im Vollbild, dass wir uns den Twitch-Chat nicht geben müssen, wobei, Twitch-Chat, jetzt mal ernsthaft, Leute, ja,
ist das, was Twitch gut macht, ohne Twitch-Chat und ohne die Twitch-Emotes und alles, wäre das einfach nur, äh, Mixer 0.1 oder so, ja, manchmal weiß ich selbst nicht, was ich, was ich erzähle, zumal ich den Mixer erst mache, naja, was auch immer, ihr wisst, was ich meine, Twitch-Chat ist das, das Beste, muss, kommt auch mal wieder ein neues Video, ja, wann weiß ich noch nicht,
Leute, gibt's Qualitätseinstellungen, okay, wisst ihr, was ich geändert hab, äh, seit, seit gestern zu heute an den Settings, also, warum es jetzt Qualitätseinstellungen gibt, wisst ihr, was ich geändert hab, rhetorische Frage, was hab ich denn jetzt eigentlich gepostet auf Twitter, nichts, genau, der Seil killt's mir, hat's erkannt, nix, die letzten Streams waren alle exakt mit den gleichen Settings, so, gut,
jetzt müsste es gleich losgehen,
ich mach schon mal die Musik aus,
und gucken wir mal, dass uns der VLC-Player nicht jebaitet, wir gucken jetzt mal auf Twitch, ob's losgeht,
und wenn's losgeht, schalte ich um auf den VLC, weil Fullscreen und so, na,
hallo, oh,
Achtung, wie los,
also, es ist Absicht, dass, also, ich, ich hab keinen Sound gerade, ne,
also, jetzt, okay, gut,
wie sie lauter, ne,
ihr müsst mir gleich sagen, wenn ihr anfangt zu labern, wie der Sound ist,
das FPS in meinem Namen,
oh, jetzt müssen wir erstmal zuhören,
Square Enix,
Natürlich gibt es auch neue Informationen, also lasst uns bis zum Ende des Videos sehen.
Nun, es beginnt endlich.
Lasst uns zusammen genießen.
Es gibt einen Moment in jeder Lebenszeit,
in dem wir eine Wahl machen müssen.
Lass die Welt unseren Destinaten formen.
Oder kämpfen, um jemand zu werden, der wir sein sollen.
Das heißt nicht Tomb Raider, das heißt Tomb Raider.
Sprich das korrekt aus wie Tomb Raider, ja?
Nicht Tomb Raider, Tomb Raider.
Sowas von, oh stopp, sonst scamtalkt man.
Irgendwann kaufe ich Tomb Raider auf Amazon.
Bisschen leise, oder?
Ich mach, ich mach hier nach, lauter.
Wow.
Hi, my name is Daniel Chaibisson, Game Director at Eros Montreal.
So ist besser, ne?
Tomb Raider, which will deliver on Lara Croft's defining moment,
as she raced to stop a Maya Apocalypse.
Lara will have to confront...
150% Lautstärke, ja.
...in order to survive.
And even though that she's more confident and more capable,
she will still be outgunned and outnumbered by Trinity.
She will have to use everything she learned from the jungle
and use it in order to survive.
We call this becoming one with the jungle.
Let's take a look at what this means for gameplay.
Cool story, bro.
You guys come through here?
Tau Team, Croft is on a venture towards your position.
I say again, Croft is coming to you.
Jesus Christ.
Shh, we'll get her, sir.
Show me her corpse and your entire team is next to me for beacon training.
Roark out.
Terrible.
I'll kill you all!
Jesus.
Die Wachen in den Stealth-Games müssen halt einfach dumm sein
Es geht nicht anders
Sieht keiner
So, oh, eine Flasche
Hm, was könnte das sein?
Na, hier ist bestimmt keiner
Ich laufe jetzt alleine in die Richtung, ohne was zu sagen
Und bam
In your face
Stealth-Kill
Und er merkt es auch nicht, ne?
Das ganze Team wird abgemetzelt hinter ihm
Aber
Wachen in Stealth-Games, da ist nix mit 200 IQ
Da ist
45 IQ, wenn es hochkommt
Also, Wachen in Stealth-Games
Guckt euch den mal an hier jetzt
Und dabei hat er schon
Hat die grad Sam Fisher umgebracht
Zumindest hat er so ein geiles Sam-Fisher-Nacht-Sichtgerät
Gotta check in with Maltese
Sure, gives me something to do
Hey, you know Maltese's access code?
01-03-53-Mike
Hey, heading over there now
Give you some backup, dude
This place is empty
Body here
Looks recent
Parts up
They can't be far
Gotta find out what's going on
View, big point
Here you see
In the bush you'll see
Yes, through the bush?
Sure, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure
Keiner. Ist klar. Wie in echt.
Kommt das der mit der
Kettensäge oder
was knattert da so?
Ich hoffe, die bringen keine Tiere
im Trailer um. Muss man gleich Peter
callen, wenn es soweit ist.
Weil das geht ja nicht. Wachenab
darfst du abmetzeln, aber
irgendwelche Tiere aus dem Dschungel, das geht nicht.
We see, Klepp.
Es sieht aus wie die letzten zwei, oder?
360?
Das ist die ultimative
Definitiv
Tomb Raider. Oh, oh, Peter.
Was ich ja immer genial finde, egal ob bei
Uncharted, bei Tomb Raider, bei
irgendwelchen Filmen, ja,
dass die so,
dass die da immer in irgendwelche Gräber
reinsteigen mit uraltem Zeug
seit tausend von Jahren und das
funktioniert alles wunderbar.
Oh, hab ich
500 Stunden oder so
gespielt, bis es kein Content mehr gab.
Mit dem Frasier zusammen.
Das war an sich
ein ziemlich gutes MMO.
Das Problem war, es hatte
kein Endgame-Content.
Und den, den es hatte,
der war noch künstlich beschnitten.
So nach dem Motto,
sammle 50 Tokens, aber du darfst
pro Token plus, äh, pro Woche
plus 5 Tokens sammeln.
Ach, das war ein Trainer für den Patch.
Das ist für ein neues Add-on oder sowas.
Moment, ist das hier ein Crossover
oder was?
What?
Okay, ich weiß zwar nicht genau, was es geht, aber
warum nicht? Moment, das hatten wir doch
gestern schon.
Das kommt mir bekannt vor. Haben wir das nicht gestern schon gesehen?
Ja, das haben wir auch bei Microsoft schon gesehen.
Genau.
Captain, Captain irgendwas. Ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie es hieß.
Captain Spirit, genau.
My name is Michel Kaur.
And my name is Raoul Barbet.
We are the two creative directors of
Life is Strange at Dontman Entertainment.
As you may know, we have just revealed
the awesome adventures of Captain Spirit.
It's a brand new story in the Life is Strange
universe. And this
full experience will be available to download
for free on the 26th of June.
To us, Life is Strange is not a single
download or set of characters.
Captain Spirit is our way
for introducing the players to the
many stories we want to tell in this
expanded universe. Captain Spirit is
not Life is Strange 2, but it will
be your first steps into this world.
The game is hiding many
secrets and even some links to
the brand new story and characters
of Season 2. So make sure you
take all your time to explore. We cannot wait
for you to experience Chris' story.
We hope you will enjoy it.
Have a great history and
from all the Life is Strange team
and Dontnod. Thank you.
Thank you. Bye bye.
Now I just need to make a cool
costume for Captain Spirit.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich davon halten soll.
Also,
wenn sie eine gute Story machen,
warum nicht?
Es fehlt eher ein Spiel mit guter
Geschichte. Aber ich habe
bis jetzt noch nichts gesehen, was so der Aufhänger
von der Story sein soll.
Man sieht halt ein junges Superhelden-Spiel. Das ist ja nicht so,
dass es nicht so ist.
Dass es nicht... Ja, ein paar gibt es, die
sowas machen.
Oh, das ist Dragon Quest.
Sieht zumindest genauso aus wie Dragon Quest.
Das ist schon Dragon Quest.
Oder irgendein Mobile Dragon Quest.
Ne, das ist das...
Ne, ne, das ist das Neue.
Dragon Quest 85 oder so.
You've brushed with death a thousand times.
Yet still you have your life.
Dragon Quest Royal, genau.
It is your fate to save this world.
Da warte ich noch drauf.
Dragon Quest Royal.
Ich meine, es gab ja schon alle möglichen
Dragon Quest Ableger.
Warum nicht auch Dragon Quest Royal?
Let the light shine on the world again.
Fate hangs by a thread.
We must fight fire with cold steel.
All that matters is power.
And the only power that matters
is that of the darkness.
JRPG halt.
It's time to claim your birthright.
Gruppe aus 16 Jahren muss die Welt retten.
Aber so ist das halt.
So muss das sein.
Das war aber Cup of Pride
ohne Ende gerade.
Ich bilde mir ein, das ist doch in Japan
sogar schon raus.
Oh, Dragon Ball.
Dragon Ball.
Das ist in Japan doch schon raus.
Guck mal, Rotkörbchen ist auch am Start.
Ah, die Hapada.
Ah, das werde ich mir auf jeden Fall holen,
wenn das was taugt.
Schon lange kein ordentliches JRPG-Match-Spiel.
Merke, paar Mädels,
weniger Rüstung,
gleich mehr Rüstung.
Ich mein, geile Soundtracks haben die schon immer.
Da kann man nix sagen.
Was könnte das sein?
Hm.
Ist das...
Ist das irgendein Warhammer oder sowas?
Nee.
Ich hab keinen Schimmer.
Okay.
Was Neues?
Hey!
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Von für den PC.
Das ist...
Nier Automata Extreme
Definite Dingsbums Edition.
Ultimate Mega Edition.
Mit Blatt Royal.
Die Masterpiece Edition.
Ein Become...
Was?
Komm-Es-Gottes-Edition.
Komischer Satz.
Das geht Schlag auf Schlag bei Square Enix.
Ist das Final Fantasy Tactics oder sowas?
Sowas ähnliches, hä?
Was für die Switch!
Für die Switch Drama?
рубritsch
travel meme
Was für die Switch ...
R gewinnst du technological
für die Switcholi It suchs
Ach, nicht genugend v殺
vack
Last Chance
Krack
Good
Johnny
No
The last chance
Love
Das ist der größte und am langweiligsten Weltraum, den wir jemals geschaffen haben.
Jeder Reise in Solis wird Geschichte, Geheimnisse und Gefahr entdecken.
Nie hat ein Just Cause-Spiel eine größere Vielfalt,
reich in allen Formen der Leben, geöffnet.
Am ersten Blick ist Solis ein wunderschönes Lokal.
Aber schraubt die Oberfläche und du wirst Oppression, Angst und Gewalt entdecken.
Alles entdeckt von Gabriella,
dem Leiter der privaten Militärorganisation, der Black Hand.
Just Cause 4 bringt Zerstörung und Physik-Simulationen zu einem ganz neuen Niveau,
mit der Erklärung von extremen Wäldern.
Erlebt von Tornaden, die Trennungen aus dem Boden und Stöße zu Stößen zerstören.
Tolle, gebrannte Leitungen, unvergessliche und sterbliche Sandstorme und röhrende Gläser.
Beobachte die spektakuläre Zerstörung,
weil sie die Herausforderung Rika und die Wunder zugegeben haben.
Es ist eine kreative Sandbox-Gameplay.
Alle Fahrzeuge sind völlig überholt,
mit neuen Verwendungen, die zusätzliche Spielmöglichkeiten bieten.
Bulldozer,
Fahrzeugtransporter,
Kranen
und sogar Reckon-Ballons
werden von der Welt überholt.
Wir handeln nur ein kleines Auto,
voll mit exotischen Fahrzeugen, wie Jetskis und Mikrojets.
Rikos Grappel ist jetzt vollständig kustomisierbar
und es wurde überholt, um es intuitiver zu machen.
Ein Neukommer.
Während er eine größere Bedeutung für einen mehr erfahrenen Spieler bietet.
Der Grappel hat jetzt mehr Teile als je zuvor.
Und die Fähigkeit, Booster-Roketten in den neuen Luftfahrzeugen zu erzeugen,
macht den Grappel eine unglaublich kraftvolle und kreative Ziele.
In der Zwischenzeit,
verbindet sich eine neue Geschichte.
Unsere freie Form,
geh-wohin-wohin-wohin-wohin-Gameplay,
die Jetskis so berühmt ist,
und die Fälle für Riko sind noch nie hoch.
Die Kampf- und Just-Cause-4 ist besser als alles.
Die Feinde präsentieren jetzt einen viel intelligenteren Threat für Riko.
Jedes Archetype kommt mit einzigartigen Fähigkeiten,
mit AI, das den Spieler auf sich selbst behalten kann.
Solis ist eine tieflich weiterentwickelte, systemische Welt.
Und alles, was du gesehen hast,
von der unglaublich physikalisierten Zerstörung
bis zur unparallelsten Dreh-Distanz,
wird von der brandneuesten Best-in-Klasse unterstützt.
Das Open-World-Apex-Engine.
Okay, zumindest kommt es auf allen Plattformen.
Das ist doch schon mal was.
Das heißt, wenn man die Reihe mag,
kann man es überall spielen.
Mirror's Edge 25.
Wobei, nein.
Falscher.
Falscher Hersteller.
Oh, du?
Ah.
Und jetzt Ingame-Grafik.
Was überhaupt nicht auffällt, der Übergang.
Warum hat man das nicht gleich in-game gezeigt?
Jetzt ist wieder...
Hä?
Ich mein...
Als hätte man das jetzt nicht gesehen.
Ich weiß nicht.
Warum musste das jetzt in echt sein und das andere in-game?
Hä?
Okay, jetzt kommt Kingdom Hearts.
Das ist genau das Gleiche, haben sie gestern ja schon gezeigt.
Das ist exakt der gleiche Trailer.
Oder?
Doch, ist es.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, der die Kingdom Hearts-Story checkt?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was da abgeht, ey.
Hahaha.
Jetzt ist es mir zu hoch.
Das ist großartig.
Du kannst Eis kontrollieren.
Kontrollieren?
Nein.
Alles, was ich jemals tue, ist, Leute zu schmerzen.
Ja!
Gib mir Kraft!
Also, ich hab nur das erste gespielt auf der PS2.
Ja, Flamios beste Erklärung.
Das ist ein Typ, der schlägt alle mit dem Schlüssel.
Ach, komm.
Immer noch, Sora.
Das bedeutet nicht, dass du wechseln sollst.
Erhalte die Kraft, die dir gegeben wird.
Finde die Herzen, die in den Hörern verbunden sind.
Der Hörer.
Ich werde dir die Geschichte erzählen.
Die Welt ist von bösen Mächten bedroht.
Und der Oberbösewicht möchte der Herrscher über das komplette Universum oder sonst was werden.
Und die Helden müssen ihn retten.
Also, die Welt.
Das Universum.
Alles.
Das war nämlich was ganz innovatives.
Das hat es doch noch nie gegeben.
Also, was wird noch akzeptiert?
Ich weiß.
Ich will es wissen.
Roxas existiert.
Seine Herzen sind in meinem Herzen.
In diesem Fall.
Allgemein.
Nichts würde uns mehr gefallen, als dass Roxas zurückkehrt.
Roxas und Roxas?
Ja.
Für den virtuellen Weltraum komplett zu erkennen, würde Anselm der Geist Roxas volle Daten
in der Konstruktion haben.
Ja.
In der Konstruktion?
Hmmm...
This Keyblade...
Is that...!
Kimmichie?
You're too late.
Ich...
Ich glaube die Story, die von Kingdom Hearts es es gibt keinen, der die checkt.
Das ist so eine der wirsten Geschichten, die es überhaupt gibt.
Was, fertig?
Es ist fertig, oder?
Sieht aus wie der Outro Trailer.
Na ja.
Im Prinzip warum nicht.
Prinzip, warum nicht?
Spiele gezeigt?
Gutes.
So könnte es überall sein.
Zwei Stunden, wie genial sie sind.
Gelaber muss doch nicht sein.
Einfach Spiele zeigen, gut ist.
So, was ist denn die nächste?
Mal gucken, wann...
Ich glaube, die ist aber zu spät für mich.
Ich glaube, die PC Games...
Die hatten da was.
Ja.
Also.
Gut.
Ja, Termine.
So, als nächstes haben wir dann...
Oh, nee.
Ey, 22 Uhr.
Ich muss morgen 5.45 Uhr aufstehen.
Das ist zu spät.
Könnt ihr das mal zu ordentlichen EU-Zeiten machen?
Also, zu Final Fantasy 7 kein Wort.
Was mich ein bisschen verwirrt.
Weil das haben die ja schon auch wieder vor...
Keine Ahnung, 2, 3 Jahren oder so angekündigt.
Und irgendwann haben sie gesagt, das kommt jetzt in Episoden.
Und da hat man nichts davon gehört.
So, ich muss mal kurz in den Chat gucken.
Also, wie gesagt, ich habe ja nichts beantwortet zwischendurch.
Weil ich nicht zu sehr reinlabern wollte.
Ich guck mal, ob es da irgendwas Interessantes gibt.
Ähm...
Was arbeitest du, dass du so früh aufstehen musst?
Ich stehe freiwillig so früh auf.
Da kann ich nämlich früher wieder heimgehen.
Ha?
Früher kommen, früher gehen.
So ist es.
Big Brain.
Ja.
Ähm...
Kann man deinen Stream nachher als Video sehen?
Ja klar, das ist alles bei Twitch.
Oder alternativ gehst du auf die Archiv-Seite von Silbaro.
Da sind alle Streams seit...
Ach, soll er selbst schreiben.
Ich weiß nicht seit wann.
Was ist eigentlich deine aktuelle Meinung zur Switch?
Ich denke immer noch, das Konzept ist gut.
Die Hardware ist gut.
Also schnell genug, reicht.
Keine Schmerzen damit.
Das Problem ist, dass es kaum Games gibt, die was für mich sind.
Und dass der Online-Modus sowas von rückständig ist.
Das muss man gar nicht erwähnen.
Mal gucken, was Nintendo da ankündigt morgen.
So.
Hast du nie Automata gespielt?
Nope.
So, leider kann ich nicht weiter zurück scrollen.
So, wir können jetzt mal kurz gucken irgendwo.
Was haben denn die anderen angekündigt?
Also was haben wir verpasst?
Wir haben Devolver verpasst und wir haben Bethesda verpasst.
Gucken wir doch mal.
Ich muss mal...
Ich muss mal Stellung T anbinden.
Summary.
Gucken wir mal, was da war.
Recap.
All Trailers.
Ja, das ist gut.
Wollen wir uns das noch angucken?
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob es auf YouTube irgendwie ein Bethesda Summary oder sowas gibt?
Wie spricht man die eigentlich richtig aus?
Batesta?
Bethesda?
Also ich bin für Bethesda.
Bethesda Summary.
Warte mal.
Wir hatten doch eben was mit All Trailers.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
All Trailers.
Was auch immer das für ein Blog ist.
Gbait.
Clickbait.
Okay.
Ah, das ist dann eine ganz gute Auflistung.
Machen wir aus.
Also.
Das erste, was sie gezeigt haben, war anscheinend Rage 2.
Rage 1 war ja unglaublich langweilig.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen, YouTube?
Alter.
Welch eins war übelst langweilig.
Schreien.
Wichtig.
Oh, Gameplay.
Zeig mal her.
Ja, rumgefahren ist man in Rage 1 auch viel.
Und ich fand das Fahren in Rage 1 auch übelst langweilig.
Ich fand ganzes Rage 1 übelst langweilig.
Rage Royale.
Okay, ist blättert.
Deswegen war das ab 18.
So dangerous sind die jetzt aber nicht, oder?
Das ist auch Last Man Standing, wie es aussieht.
Okay, baller, baller, baller.
Rennen, baller, baller, baller.
Shotguns leiden, in die Eier schießen.
Baller, baller.
Also quasi Rage 1.
Bloß vielleicht ohne.
Die langweiligsten Parts zwischendurch.
Das erinnert mich jetzt fast schon ein bisschen an Doom.
Danke für die 5 Euro, Mr. Har...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Mr. Haribo.
Mr. Haribo 1.
Ich habe keine Donation vergessen.
Die baitet mich nicht.
Sieht aus, als würde Ranger Walker heute ein bisschen einen Boost bekommen.
Also ein bisschen erinnert es mich schon an Doom, ne?
Das ist natürlich auch sehr klaffer.
Du hast einen Boss, der nur Mehle kann.
Du rennst hin.
Jetzt rastest du hier.
Big Brain.
Das könnte was werden.
Also es könnte ernsthaft was werden.
Es kommt halt darauf an, ob die langweiligen Parts dazwischen nicht wieder
kompletten Spaß töten.
So, was haben sie noch gezeigt?
Älder Scrolls Le...
Das ist ein Kartenspiel, ne?
Grill.
Okay, Hearthstone.
Hearthstone Mobile mit Controller.
Bloß, dass es nicht Hearthstone ist.
This is for any way you play.
This is for anywhere you play.
This is for strategy fans.
This is for those who want magic at their fingertips.
This is for those who want dragons at their command.
This is a game where legends are born.
Auf der Switch, immerhin.
Gut.
Die wollen halt auch...
Ne?
Die wollen halt auch einen Hearthstone-Klon haben.
Elder Scrolls Online Trailer.
Okay, das ist bestimmt für eine neue Expansion.
So.
Das finde ich super, sich das im Nachhinein anzugucken.
Da fällt das Ganze gelabert zwischendurch weg.
Wisst ihr?
Wisst ihr keinen, dass sie so committed sind und dass sie die besten Fans haben
und dass sie die Plattform immer vorantreiben werden bis ans Ende aller Tage
und nur auf...
Ne, aber, ne?
Einfach Trailer und gut, das...
Das gestern Live-Band-Auftritt bei Bethesda war ultra cringe.
Dass wenn es ultra cringe war, müssen wir uns das angucken.
Ähm, ich hab damals die Beta gespielt.
Also, als Elder Scrolls Online neu war.
Und ich...
Das war so...
Ähm...
Ich weiß nicht...
Es hat mich so wenig beeindruckt, dass ich gar nicht mehr weiß, was mir nicht gefallen hat.
Es hat mir zumindest so wenig gefallen, dass ich gar nicht dran gedacht habe, mir die Vollversion zu holen.
Aber irgendwann muss man auch mal reinkashen.
Man muss ja auch Kohle verdienen.
Mit MMOs kann man...
Vor allem mit Abo-Modellen...
Ist das noch Abo? Ist das noch Sub? Oder ist das Free-to-Play?
Weiß das jemand von euch?
Free-to-Play oder Abo?
Am Anfang war es nämlich, glaube ich, Abo.
Mittlerweile ist es bestimmt Free-to-Play.
Nice Musik.
Okay, wem...
Wer da spielt? Spielt das jemand von euch?
Doom Eternal. Aha.
Spielt das jemand von euch?
Also nicht Doom Eternal.
Elder Scrolls Online?
Okay. Ähm...
Next.
Doom Eternal.
Ey, die Beta habe ich auch gespielt.
Ja, PvP war einfach Crap.
Beim letzten Doom.
Da hatten sie ja so eine Marketing-Kampagne am Laufen,
wo sie sich wieder ein paar bekannte Influencer
geholt haben für das Game.
Die das Game dann loben mussten.
Das haben wir nicht loben mussten, aber auch nicht unbedingt so viel
Schlechtes drüber sagen.
Und trotzdem war der Multiplayer einfach scheiße.
Okay.
Warum nicht?
Der letzte Teil war gut.
Nehmen wir...
Quake Champions. Jawoll.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was
da draus wird.
Also das ist ja schon spielbar.
Moment, ist ein bisschen leise, hä?
Oh, es wird bestimmt noch lauter.
Ne.
Gibt ja auch viele
Quake-Pros, die wieder Quake Champions spielen, jetzt.
Wenn man mal auf Twitch guckt.
Ja, kennt man... Ich meine, das gibt's ja schon.
Also jeder, der das Spiel will, kann's schon spielen.
Muss man nicht drauf warten.
Und ich hatte am Anfang ja die Bedenken,
als sie das allererste gezeigt haben
von dem Game, dass das viel zu sehr
in Richtung MOBA beziehungsweise Overwatch
abklatscht geht, aber ist es gar nicht.
Also für alle, die Quake mochten,
werden das wahrscheinlich auch mögen.
Also wem Quake gefällt, für den ist das
mit Sicherheit was.
Oh, neues Prey.
Ach ne, DLC, okay.
Debated.
Eigentlich fast schon
Scamast.
Prey Mooncrash Trailer.
Gucken wir uns halt den Trailer nicht
beim offiziellen Channel an.
So.
Gucken wir uns halt den Trailer bei...
Was ich?
Da an.
Bin ja zu laut.
Hab ich nicht gespielt?
Soll gut gewesen sein.
Hatte aber mit dem Teil davor
überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Quake war das nicht die andere
Tournament-Kopie. Ne, eher umgedreht.
Außerdem haben die Spiele nicht so viel
miteinander gemein gehabt.
Die Werte, die die Werte und die Werte
sind, sind immer anders,
jedes Mal, wenn man spielt.
Und, all of this,
die kostenlosen Updates,
Mooncrash, die Digital Deluxe Edition
sind alle heute vorhanden.
Wir sind so gespannt.
Wir warten nicht auf...
Was?
Die Erde ist eine harte Frau.
Sie wird es für dich bekommen.
Lass uns arbeiten.
Lass, lass, lass, lass,
Das steht auch
noch auf meiner Liste.
Ich hab's nicht gespielt.
Ich weiß nicht warum.
Das hat ja überall auch gute Bewertungen gekriegt.
Ach, das ist...
Was ist denn das?
Ich meine, ernsthaft?
Der macht hinterher offizielle...
Macht er sein Bittesubscriben?
WTF?
Was?
Das...
eine wahnsinnige Leistung, den offiziellen Trailer
hochzuladen bei sich.
Ein neues Wolfenstein.
Die wollen es aber wissen,
oder? Was
bei Patrasta allerdings irgendwo klappt, ist,
die Spiele taugen meistens was, obwohl es
ein Aufguss ist.
Hä?
Ach, hab ich verklickt.
Oh, come on, ey.
Young,
Blood.
Announcement Trailer.
Ja.
Wie die immer gebeten.
Moment, wir wollen von Anfang an gucken.
Oh, oh.
Bent. Bent.
Das hat keiner gesehen. Bent.
Oh, ne.
Bent.
It's about how much you can take.
It's do or die.
Wolfenstein Grill Edition.
Skyrim Very Special Edition.
Okay, das ist bestimmt ein Gag, ne?
Weil ich mein, Skyrim
gibt's ja schon in allen erdenklichen Varianten.
The Elder Scrolls speak of the past
and the future.
Now Skyrim looks to the future,
to its ultimate version.
PC?
Alexa, play Skyrim.
You're level 57 and see a tall snowy mountain.
Climb it now.
Skyrim and life become one.
A mud crab scuttles towards you.
Fussmoda!
I didn't catch that.
I didn't quite catch that.
Das ist ja echt gut gemacht.
You shout echoes all the way to Sovngarde.
What happened?
Fussmoda.
Is there a command for knocking things over?
Is there a command for picking shit up?
Skyrim,
Alexa Edition.
I haven't reached that level yet.
I'm sworn to carry your burdens.
The dragon unleashes fire breath on you.
You have 7% health left.
Oh shit.
I drink a health potion.
You are out of health potions.
How many wheels of cheese do I have left?
473.
Okay, I eat all the cheese.
I eat all of the cheese.
All of it.
Hey, hun.
Remember what the doctor said about dairy.
Yes.
Right, yes, of course.
You're the greatest.
Thank you so much.
I eat all of the cheese.
Introducing Skyrim.
Very special edition.
Also coming soon to Etch-a-Sketch.
Motorola Pagers.
Oh.
And your Samsung smart.
At least they can make fun of themselves.
Oh, that's cool.
The elders should know that.
Take everything with a lot of humor.
Instead,
that Phil Spencer stands up
and tells the same thing four times at Microsoft.
He told really every time
that he was on the stage yesterday.
Exactly the same cramp.
You should rather produce something like that.
That would be funny.
So, Fallout 69.
We know that already.
From Microsoft.
So.
300 Years after Great Nation began,
Ja, das ist der gleiche Trailer, den kennen wir schon.
Fucking Trees.
Corona.
Es wird bestimmt kein grottisches Game.
Ob es richtig gut wird, muss ich zeigen.
Das letzte Mal ist nicht so mein Fall.
Aber es wird bestimmt nicht grottenschlecht.
Amerika muss gerebildet werden.
Die restliche Welt ist vollkommen egal.
Hauptsache Amerika wird gebildet.
So muss das sein.
So, was haben wir noch?
Elder Scrolls Plates.
Was?
Mobile.
Was ist das?
Oh.
Come on, bra.
Muss das sein?
Harkening back to the first Elder Scrolls Arena.
This game features both handcrafted and procedurally generated dungeons.
And it's not just melee.
You have a range of abilities that elders can use.
Sieht ultra langweilig aus.
Of course, you can create your own character and be who you want to be.
Das Kampfsystem sah so statisch aus, so langweilig.
So langweilig.
gedacht. Was ist das? FOF 24 oder was? Was ist das für ein FOF jetzt? Geht das überhaupt noch? FOF 5.
Das sagt halt gar nichts aus, wenn die einfach da irgendwas aufgezeichnet zeigen. Ob das wirklich so geil aussieht, ob das sich so gut spielt. Das sagen ja alle.
Und das Kampfsystem. Das Kampfsystem sieht einfach schlecht aus. Einfach total hakelig und langweilig. Mobile halt. Mobile Crap. Instant Refund.
Wobei, warum Refund? Ich kaufe es mir gar nicht.
Das ist da, wo man Microtransactions kaufen kann. Und Ingame-Währung. Und Lootboxen.
Und Skins. Und Pets.
So Animal Crossing, ey. Naja, Mobile halt. Ja. Gut, next.
Starfield. Sagt mir gar nichts.
Okay, das war absolut nichtssagend.
Auch kein Release-Datum. Das war absolut nichtssagend.
Das ist wirklich komplett nichtssagend.
What? What? Ernsthaft?
Mobile.
Okay, das ist auch sehr nichtssagend. Aber ich glaube, alle Elder Scrolls Fans werden sich freuen, dass es jetzt offiziell ist.
Jetzt ist es ja gut mit dem Battle Royale-Witz.
Irgendwann lache ich auch immer drüber.
So, ähm, was haben wir noch verpasst gestern?
Ups.
Ah, ich muss was anbinden.
So, was haben wir noch verpasst?
Was ist jetzt los?
Warum läuft da was?
PC Games.
Come on, bro. Wo ist hier was an?
Stay tuned. Für was denn?
Für was sollen wir stay tuned bleiben?
Ne.
Was haben wir noch verpasst?
Die Volvo haben wir noch verpasst.
Gab's da was Interessantes? Ja, gucken wir nochmal.
Summary. Guck mal, was die gebracht haben.
Press Conference Recap.
Also, was haben die gezeigt?
Was ist das? Muss man sich da von irgendwas angucken?
Muss man sich von die Volvo irgendwas angucken?
Achso, das war wieder, okay, das war wieder so eine Debate-Pressekonferenz, um die anderen ein bisschen zu verarschen.
Gucken wir mal.
Die Volvo E3.
E3 2018.
Full Press Conference.
Wollen wir es uns noch geben, Leute? 15 Minuten.
Dann haben wir im Prinzip alles, was heute Nacht gelaufen ist, jetzt mal in einer halben Stunde aufgeholt.
Microsoft haben wir geguckt.
Dann sind wir wieder up to date. Square Enix haben wir geguckt.
Ubisoft.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Ubisoft mache heute.
Eigentlich ist es zu spät. Eigentlich ist es zu spät.
Das ist aber nicht der Anfang.
Moment.
Nicht Live Reaction.
Ah, da muss man mal, ja.
Gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal auf Twitch irgendwo.
Moment, nein.
Das, nee, nee, das ist was anderes.
Ähm, ja gut, da gucken wir uns jetzt halt hier irgendwas von an.
Ich hätte halt gerne was, wo...
Okay, das ist anscheinend der Anfang.
Was, das lief auf dem Twitch-Channel?
Dem da?
Ich habe es nicht gesehen jetzt.
Passt, guck mal, passt, passt.
Broadcast?
Nö.
Irgendwie nicht.
Na gut, dann gucken wir jetzt das hier.
Ach, auf dem richtigen Twitch-Channel.
Ja, das...
Was haben die denn für einen?
Keine Ahnung.
Ah.
Hier geht's los.
Ist zu leise.
Okay, das geht nicht lang. 15 Minuten nur.
Und irgendeiner meinte doch, am Anfang bei Bethesda war es übelst cringe.
Für übelst cringe bin ich immer zu haben.
Das müssen wir uns danach auch noch kurz angucken.
We're coming to our little shindig here at the Dave Land...
What an event, am I right?
Big deal.
Heckin' big deal.
Give it all the way up for the Expo, everybody.
Yes.
Look at that.
That's all you.
You're killing it.
Killing it.
And you know what?
So are we.
Lots of changes at Devolver since the last time we were here.
Lots of changes.
Lots of progress.
Synergies aligned.
Efficiencies modulated.
New management and a bold new business.
Gut, die machen das, deswegen sind wir ganz lustig.
And we couldn't have done any of that.
We stepped it up, you guys.
Stepped it all the way up.
We've examined the industry and our place in it.
We worked hard to widen our excellence perimeter.
Ich meine, die verarschen das ganze Business,
gelabert ja schon ganz gut.
Super excited.
We had some proper shit to say about our press conference last year.
That it wasn't professional.
That it didn't feel like a real video games conference
by a real video games publisher,
what publishes real video games.
That it was all some kind of joke.
Joke.
Well, you were super wrong.
And to prove it,
we have ramped up this year's Jiminy-Thinger
to include everything that you might expect
from a production of this magnitude.
This year, we have overly flashy graphics
to distract you from mundane dialogue.
Guest appearances from personalities that you can recognize
and project some misplaced familiarity onto
because you have seen them in videos on the internet.
And whose parents will serve to light up
a predictable night.
Nostalgia response.
And it is 2018 and that is how marketing is done now.
We also have...
Ja, x Sterbehilfe.
Sie haben sowas ähnliches letztes Jahr schon mal gemacht.
...a new game on the screen,
despite it clearly being a pre-scripted sequence,
meticulously planned out and pre-recorded months in advance.
But what stood out most of all?
What really stood out in the flaming trash pile idiot island
in the unending...
...Ocean of unrequested feedback from last year's press conference
was that you, simpletons,
yes, you,
you stinking bug-fuck-shit-minions
seemed to think that we didn't provide enough new games,
reveals, first looks,
or whatever else you think might have made your dumb little life
a little less pointless than that one moment on the internet
that one time.
And that...
...that hit us right in the feels.
So this year, we are bringing you those new games,
those first looks,
those reveals for projects that you never thought possible.
The first is from GamePires.
It is their SuperMax Survival Sim Scum.
You should buy it.
It is going to make us huge numbers.
It's probably pretty great, but I won't know,
because I do not play any of this garbage.
Scum Season 2 is gearing up
with TechOne's most violent offenders on display
in our award-winning survival broadcast.
With over three times as many drones,
viewers will enjoy the contestants' most intimate moments.
The fuck?
New weapons and gear elevate the action.
But it's the trademark paranoia
that drives the savagery to new heights,
making Scum a thrill for the entire family.
Fear not.
TechOne security is on.
Was zum Teufel gucken wir uns da gerade an?
Oh my.
Bäh.
And of course, fan-favorite Mr. Smiles is back again for rule enforcement.
What?
Right has been terminated.
Scum, welcome to the next era in SuperMax Survival.
What?
Da weiß man jetzt gar nicht, ob man debated wird oder nicht.
All contestant corpses,
will be reused in Scum for government regulation.
Scum Game.
Welcome to scumgame.com for more information or don't.
I get paid either way.
Up next, we have...
Moment, Leute.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Moment.
Die scheinen das ernst zu meinen.
Okay, die meinen das ernst.
Das war kein Debate.
Das gibt's wirklich.
Ob's natürlich nicht doch letztendlich irgendwie ein Gag ist,
keine Ahnung.
Aber ich muss ja auch Geld verdienen.
Endlich.
Ladies and Gentlemen, I am thrilled to introduce you to our newest product.
Loot Box Coin.
Endless.
Owners know its actual value.
Totally unregulated and absent of all civil, governmental, international, personal or institutional liability.
Loot Box Coin aims to become the global standard in meaningless wealth acquisition and questionable financial stability.
Loot Box Coin cannot be mined, cannot be opened, cannot be blockchained, cannot be walleted or crypto verified.
And what can you do with it? Nothing.
It can only be bought through Devolver Digital with real, actual money you have in your actual bank account.
This is really well done this time again with the band.
One of our hastily trained economists will create and send you an actual, physical loot box coin just like the one I am holding right here in my motherfucking hand.
What is it worth? I don't know.
What can you buy with it? Probably nothing.
Does the US government consider it a form of gambling? Fuck if I care.
Loot Box Coin.
Moment.
Schmuck, I'm gonna stupidis about...
That was out of the subject.
They say, at least they take what they signed off to be seriously
asi.
Well, you can find that in the shop.
By the way, when we were looking for coins,
Last time I've seen something that was on amazon.
Haha, I believe someone didn't quite understand the system.
Is that not exactly the opposite of what I thought?
Like this thing to GET you a Bitcoin doesn't make s...
How are you fucking kidding me.
WHY
Where's the point?
und weiß es nicht.
Kommen wir weiter.
Haben wir schon.
GIFs. Es ist ein Akronym.
Akronym ist die Präsentation des Kreators des sogenannten Akronym.
Wie ein richtiger Name.
In diesem Fall, der Kreator des Grafik-Vereinigungsformats, Steve Wilhite, sagt, es sind GIFs.
Wähle die Entwickler, wähle die GIFs.
Ansonsten, hier ist mein Freund Pedro.
Ich habe nie besonders von Gewalt gefreut.
Aber das sind schlechte Leute.
Schlechte Leute, die gestoppt werden müssen.
Also, lasst uns verrückt werden.
Lasst uns seltsam werden.
Lasst uns...
... naja, ...
... die GIFs.
Happy Wheels 3.
The past few years, we have seen a new trend in gaming hardware.
Was hat der Kerl da hinten?
Companies reaching deep into their back catalogs to construct cute as fuck little miniature fun-sized versions of their legacy hardware.
Overflowing with classic games of yesteryear, asking you to pay a ridiculous premium for games that you owned 20 years ago and will be utterly disappointed by playing again today.
Somehow.
You all are buying these things up en masse.
You are paying triple sticker price to some creep, selling them out of the back of his car next to a dumpster out behind Taco Bell.
And not the nice Taco Bell, but the sketchy one that sells fried chicken and pizza and always smells faintly of a mop bucket filled with purple drink and puke.
You love these little nostalgic cash grabs.
And we have no...
Ich meine, es ist schon was dran.
Das ist der Money Separator.
Äh, Herbst 96, wir sind schon fertig mit Square Enix.
Gucken wir uns gerade an, was wir gestern...
...gestern Nacht verpasst haben.
Jeffrey!
Ja, Mutter?
Drück diesen super legiten Live-Demo-Game-Controller und komm hier hoch.
Zeig diesen Leuten die Magie, die das Devolver Digital Entertainment System Klassik ist.
Das Devolver Digital Entertainment System Klassik packt einen SFPGA-Prozessor von der schwedischen Verkäuferin Lockett AB...
Ähm, ist das der Sega Dreamcast?
Hör auf, Jeffrey.
Rocking...
Du hast einen Sega Dreamcast gepaintert.
Ich habe ihn da draußen.
Guck, diese sind gar nicht in irgendwas eingepackt.
Das ist ein Metal Wolf Chaos-Disk, der nur auf der Xbox veröffentlicht wurde, es ist nicht mal ein Devolver-Game.
Und es ist japanisch und nicht echt, also...
Skamaz!
Margaret!
Es ist Zeit für das Game-Reveal des Abends.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Aber dieses...
Dieses wird wirklich das Blutfluss in eure Nattern bringen.
Okay, mal gucken, ob noch was Gescheites kommt.
2004.
I am taking you on a journey to 2004.
Our good friends at From Software released a game that unbeknownst to them would lay the very foundation for the modern American political landscape.
This...
This game...
This motherfucking legendary piece of cold-rolled amazing was forged...
in the most sacred elements of video game development.
Mechs, explosions, and overly dramatic voice acting.
Ladies, gentlemen, holy fucking shit.
May I present to you, From Software's 2004 Masterclass in Democratic Mech Warfare, Metal Wolf...
Was kommt mir heute sehr gerade an?
To the White House.
Hauptsache, die Musik übertrieben laut gemacht.
Die machen das wenigstens immer ganz witzig.
Ist das eigentlich wirklich die Devolver-Chefin?
Oder haben sie es an eine Schauspielerin hingestellt?
ETF.
Yep.
Let me see.
Bring in that lady.
Lock it down.
She's on.
Alright, what's the story?
You were able to save her heart.
What?
I thought we agreed on total body processes.
Now use the heart.
Was zum Geier gucke ich hier?
Ja, Terror, das fragen wir uns alle gerade.
Wir haben die zwei Sachen von gestern Nacht nachgeholt.
Und eine davon war die Volvertage.
Die war nicht das letzte.
Okay, was auch immer.
Was auch immer.
Gut, jetzt haben wir uns alles angeguckt.
Wow, bisschen laut.
Jetzt haben wir uns alles angeguckt, was wir verpasst haben.
22 Uhr heute ist noch Ubisoft.
Ich bin gerade echt am überlegen.
Nee, das ist zu spät.
Ich muss 5.45 Uhr aufstehen.
Wenn ich Ubisoft 22 Uhr...
mache
dann wer weiß wie lange die da rumschwätzen, weil Ubisoft hat es ja auch nicht gerade mit kurz und knackig
Dann bin ich erst um 24 uhr oder so im Bett und das ist zu kurz
Und wenn ich direkt nach dem Livestream ins Bett gehe, kann ich erst mal bestimmt ne Stunde nicht pennen, was die Band noch
Oh ja, ja, das ist das da Cringe Band
Die Rage Band, das ist bestimmt übelster Cringe
Was davon ist denn das Richtige?
Was ist da?
Ne
Achso, ich hab's ja falsch geschrieben
Was heißt da Briefing und Presentation?
Okay, das muss ja da drinnen sein irgendwo
Wo war das? Am Anfang oder?
Okay
The fuck?
Was ist das?
Äh
Was geht?
Das Publikum, ja, das Publikum ist echt geil
Das Publikum
Das Publikum ist gerade ungefähr so
Guckt euch das Publikum an
Es geht
The fuck?
Was?
Was genau soll?
Was genau soll uns das jetzt eigentlich sagen?
Die anderen pissen sich auch gerade weg
Die geben alles, die geben alles
Oh Leute
Das ist jetzt übel Streamception
Wir gucken uns den Restream vom Restream im Restream an
Die haben jetzt einfach mal das komplette Lied gespielt
Alter, was geht mit dem ab?
Aber super geil ist das Publikum nicht
Okay, das war die Rageband
Was auch immer
Kein Schimmer
Das Scum Game
So, jetzt müssen wir uns nochmal kurz auf Steam angucken
Okay
What?
Das ist so
Okay, das mit dem Game meinen sie tatsächlich ernst
So, wir haben uns alles angeguckt
Jetzt sind wir wieder auf dem aktuellen Stand
Dann
Gucken wir uns morgen Nintendo an
Morgen 18 Uhr
Aber wahrscheinlich 17.30 Uhr oder so
Gucken wir uns Nintendo an
Und
Danach schauen wir uns
Oder davor, je nachdem, gucken wir mal
Davor schauen wir an, was wir bei Ubisoft
Und, ne, eigentlich nur bei Ubisoft
Die PC Games
Die Gaming Show
Was auch immer da genau gezeigt wird
Dann gucken wir uns davor an
Oder danach, je nachdem, wie es von der Zeit passt
Was wir bei Ubisoft verpasst haben
Wahrscheinlich
Auflagen von Neuauflagen
Der Neuauflagen
Und in Assassin's Creed in Griechenland
Irgendwie sowas, hab ich im Hinterkopf
So, Leute
Das war's
Wir sind schon auf dem aktuellen Stand
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen
War ein bisschen kürzere Geschichte heute
Macht's gut, bis dann
See you